What do Americans think about immigration
and particularly the Dreamers?
In polls conducted since the 1960s, only small
numbers of Americans have ever wanted to increase
immigration.
Only 21 percent gave that response in 2016
when Gallup last asked the question.
Thirty eight percent wanted to keep immigration
at is present level and an identical 38 percent
wanted to decrease it.
Forty-three percent in a new Monmouth University poll say illegal immigration
is a serious problem for the United States.
But immigration attitudes are complex.
Recent polls show that Americans are becoming
more supportive of the contributions immigrants
make to our society.
And most people favor a path to citizenship
for law-abiding illegal aliens.
Americans are particularly sympathetic to
young people who were brought here as children
by parents who are illegal.
Majorities support the DACA program that gives
these young people temporary legal status,
and President Trump’s decision to end the
program is not popular, even among some Republicans.
The Monmouth poll shows that 70 percent nationally
would allow these young people to become US
citizens if they don’t have criminal records.
To learn more about my take on immigration, see the new issue of AEI's political report,
and check the links in the description below.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd like AEI scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.